this is called Eagle CAD this is a PCB
layout software currently this is the
the latest variant design for the SRF
are tiny little radio so this is how I
go from an idea of let's put these
electrical components together to let's
build an actual radio we usually
prototype we get a prototype panel made
in the UK hence most of the little green
stuff will build one or two test it once
we're happy with the design we will go
to China to get the PCBs manufactured we
end up with empty PCB boards like this
totally we get those done in China but
we've then populate that here in the UK
in the back room so we're in the Lawson
clean tech center and this is our back
workshop and this is our pick-and-place
machine which is just about ready to do
a run pick and place machine picks up
all the microscopic tiny little
components alright a 5 capacitors
resistors fixed more places them on the
board to save us having to do it with
tweezers
because it takes too long and then we go
and stick it through the oven melt the
solder cooks it and out of that we get a
finished product tucked in the shaft
here is our little oven that we use to
cook up products that's flashing oils
that all that is it doing what it's
waiting for one it's currently on a
preheat ready maintaining this
temperature it sits at around 150
degrees C and then when it cooks it
raises up to about 220 degrees C we
should start beginning with the blank
boards and the solder paste and go
through step-by-step these are some of
the PCB panels we get back from China we
get different sized panels depend on how
many we can squeeze on there and what
size we're looking at production time so
we've got 24 on there 15 on there six
four of those or sometimes we even get
the made individually if they're quite a
big board so we get panels from China in
various sizes and then we take them over
to the stencil printer and add solder
paste that will take a fresh PCB line up
from the stencil printer and we have
adjustment dials to line up and and then
we squeegee on
solder paste miss that bit this stencil
put solder paste on the area where the
components are going to sit where we
want to solder where we want to fix LEDs
or resistors and chips and then we have
a pasted board next we're going to
insert this and put it in a pick and
place machine so we take our pasted
boards and put them inside our picking
place and you see we've already got
three lined up and ready to go sometimes
we'll just have a full panel sometimes
like this we'll put three in it once
main working better the pick and place
these we call feeders these are
plug-and-play feeders this one has LEDs
mounted on it in a real it looks like an
old tape reel you know audio tape or
something it is tape you have a pocket
the components sitting and a cover tape
that holds the components in and you can
see there's an exposed component at the
point here that's an LED so we have
feeders for a range of size components
mostly the small stuff
room for a few bigger ones over here we
also have a tray full of ICS three to
eight chips where your Arduino processor
chips the machine itself has a movable X
my head with a pickup nozzle it's a very
nice robot and these are the different
size nozzles for picking up different
components we have two vision cameras
but the machine uses to look at parts as
it's moving around the check alignment
of stuff is a program that tells it
where to place all the components of
vision analysis window showing you what
it's looking at as it places components
and some of the controls this is going
to go away and build three pi lights if
I hit the button it's already knows
where everything is so the first thing
that started is load up ahead and it's
picking a component having a look
placing it pick up component have a look
place it so every time it pauses over
that white ring in the middle takes a
picture
and those vision analysis to work out
the X of Y offset and the rotation of a
cone of these picked up and it aims to
pick up the component in the center but
there's no guarantee it's going to pick
up a component exactly in the center so
it looks at the other side of the
component and works out a ex-wife
correction in relation to this
crosshairs that it's drawn when it then
places the component it applies that
correction offset so that it makes sure
the component goes exactly where it's
supposed to be 3 pi lights will take
this machining around about 15 minutes
different boards take different amount
of time depend on how many components
there are how many panels are in there
at once how many pieces so the picking
place is just finished doing its
15-minute run I can go and pick a
component and view where thinks it's put
it looking through with occurrences
placed checking the position of just a
few of the random components and see
where it's placed the components are
pushed into the solder paste so they are
reasonably well stuck I'm not gonna go
very far but we still a little careful
so we can place a pit board in the oven
clothes are up wait for it to hit
temperature and say going that's gonna
take about five minutes to cook a board
during which time it will heat up reflow
the solder paste keep it warm for a
little while and then cool it down out
of the oven we get a snackie finish
boards will take over testing and
programming to program these boards and
fish to use an Arduino base texture so
an Arduino the prototype shield on top
take freshly cool board flip it on the
little jig press the button load some
code
I don't runs tested this no yeah the
pilot has the Adreno three to a chip on
there running some code which takes text
over the serial port and displays it
running on the Raspberry Pi is a Python
sketch that it's basically monitoring my
Twitter feed anyone I follow on Twitter
when they tweet that Python sketch pulls
that tweet down and pushes it out over
the serial port to the pilot which then
scrolls the techs across the LED matrix
this is a chunk of the Arduino sketch
that's running actually on the PI light
on the throw to a chip monitoring the
serial port and carrying those
characters into the font and outputting
across the 126 LEDs on the other half of
the screen here is the python sketch
which is monitoring the Twitter feed
over the network cable and and pushing
that back out to the pilot all of this
is running on the PI completely
standalone from my computer yeah I mean
you can take that plug in a Wi-Fi dongle
and plug it in elsewhere and away you go
if you have access to those kind of
infrastructures guy here just goes tap
tap two short dots for two zeros and the
guy at Reno knows for only $2,000 it is
sunny disrupt anything this normal life
in a particular country